IMPOSSIBLE.
I'M WATERS AND THIS IS "MY
WORLD."
>> TUCKER: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON.
WE BEGIN WITH AN UNEXPECTED FOX
NEWS ALERT.
JUST MOMENTS AGO BARRY WISE
BEGAN POSTING PART TWO OF
TWITTER FILES.
THESE ARE ASSESSMENTS OF
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS FROM TWITTER
THAT HAVE BEEN HIDDEN UNDER
PREVIOUS MANAGEMENT BUT ARE NOW
BEING EXPOSED BY ELON MUSK WHO
JUST BOUGHT THE COMPANY.
SO MUSK, LAST WEEK, GAVE THE
DOCUMENTS OUT.
WISE IS UNPACKING ALL OF THIS
LIVE RIGHT NOW ON TWITTER IN A
TWITTER THREAD.
WHAT SHE HAS REVEALED SO FAR
CONFIRMS WHAT MANY SUSPECTED BUT
NONE KNEW FOR CERTAIN WHICH IS
THAT TWITTER ROUTINELY CENSORED
PROMINENT CRITICS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, DID SO IN SECRET
WITHOUT TELLING ANYONE AND WITH
NO FACTUAL JUSTIFICATION
WHATSOEVER.
THIS IS KNOWN AS SHADOW BANNING.
TWITTER DID IT ALL THE TIME.
PUBLICLY THEY DENIED DOING IT.
PEOPLE WHO WERE BEING SHADOWED
BAN SUSPECTED SOMETHING WAS UP
BUT DIDN'T KNOW.
THE TWITTER LEGAL OFFICER, A
WOMAN WHO WAS REWARDED BY THE
WIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
WORK ON THEIR BEHALF, SAY "WE DO
NOT SHADOW BAN AND WE DON'T
SHADOW BAN BASED ON POLITICAL
VIEWPOINTS OR IDEOLOGIES."
THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID AND IT WAS
A LIE AND THE DOCUMENTS BARI
WEISS IS POSTING PROVE THAT IT
WAS A LIE.
ONE OF TWITTER'S TARGETS FOR
SHADOW BANNING WAS A STANFORD
PROFESSOR, A PHYSICIAN, Ph.D..
ONE OF THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
PEOPLE IN AMERICAN MEDICINE.
SOMEONE WE'VE HAD ON THIS SHOW
MANY, MANY TIMES.
THERE WAS NO JUSTIFICATION FOR
CENSORING HIM EXCEPT HE WAS ONE
OF THE AUTHORS OF THE GREAT
BARRINGTON, WHICH INFURIATED THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTABLISHMENT
INCLUDING FAUCI.
BY OPPOSING COVID LOCKDOWNS.
HE'S SPENT HIS CAREER STUDYING
THE HEALTH FEET OF VARIOUS
POLICIES ON VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS, SO HE KNEW THAT
COVID LOCKDOWNS WOULD HARM
CHILDREN AND HE SAID SO.
THAT'S TOUCHED OUT TO BE TRUE
BUT TWITTER DOUBTLESS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORITIES
SHADOWED BANNED PROFESSOR
BHATTACHARYA.
THEY PREVENTED HIS TWEETS FROM
TRENDING WHICH MEANT MOST OF HIS
TWEETS COULDN'T BE SEEN.
ACCORDING TO WEISS, AT ONE POINT
THEY SLAPPED HIM WITH A SEARCH
BAN.
THAT MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
USERS TO FIND TWEETS BY HIM,
BECAUSE THEY WERE INACCURATE?
NO, BECAUSE THEY WERE ACCURATE.
THAT WAS THE CRIME.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE CRIME.
THEY NEVER PUNISH YOU FOR LYING,
THEY ONLY PUNISH YOU FOR TELLING
THE TRUTH.
THEY ALSO FLAGGED CHARLIE KIRK'S
ACCOUNT WITH A DO NOT AMPLIFY
ACCOUNT.
THE GROUP THAT DECIDED WHETHER
TO LIMIT THE REACH OF CERTAIN
USERS WAS THE STRATEGIC RESPONSE
TEAM, GLOBAL ESCALATION TEAM OR
SRTGET.
THE TEAM OFTEN HANDLED UP TO 200
SEPARATE CASES A DAY.
ANOTHER GROUP WITHIN TWITTER
CALLED SITE INTEGRITY, POLICY
ESCALATION SUPPORT, NOTICE
THE -- BUREAUCRATIC INTANGIBLES,
TWITTER EXECUTIVES WHO RAN THE
COMPANY.
NONE OF THIS HAS BEEN PREVIOUSLY
KNOWN.
IT WAS NEVER DISCLOS